ich finde das einfach nur eklig ich
hasse diese spinne weil wenn ich den
jungs und herzlich willkommen endlich
mal wieder zu einer neuen motto review
vorstellung
ja ich bin gut drauf und wollte euch
eine neue modifikation vorstellen und
zwar die teilnehmer die bzw pat war dies
beziehungsweise ich nenne sie einfach
haustiere modifikation ganz einfach auf
deutsch weil ihr könnt ein haustier aber
sie können jetzt keine tricks beibringen
oder so ihr habt dann einfach nur ein
kleinen gefährten und wenn ihr uns jetzt
einfach mal eine neue welt machen
creative dann werdet ihr direkt wartet
also das bin ich mehr oder weniger
sollte der ist ganz kleinen wartet
vergleichen vergleich zu mir rum
schieben oder so also die das war es
eigentlich schon der verfolgten jetzt
die ganze zeit auch so wenn ich
weglaufen oder so der teleportiert sich
dort könnt ihr sehen wenn ich relativ
weit weg bin da hatte probierte sich
weil er kann natürlich nicht sprinten
der ist ja nur ganz normal am laufen auf
kleinen wegen verfolgt damit noch jetzt
teleportiert er sich allerdings
ja wir können diese person einfach
wegschubsen können sie allerdings nicht
schlagen wir können richtig drauf machen
dann sitzt er bei uns auf dem kopf das
sieht sie aus so hier die sonne wie so
ein ding star wie hieß das noch mal ich
weiß es nicht jedenfalls können wir noch
mal richtig machen
darunter level sind und nun zum beispiel
ein schwein töten was jetzt ein bisschen
länger dauern sollte weil ich gerade
ehrlich gesagt keine lust hab einfach
ins inventar zu gehen da ist auch schon
und wenn wir zum beispiel ein rock pop
shop können wir damit einfach richtig
drauf machen und ich ja kein schwein
weglaufen das zweite portiert sich eine
therapie anbietet tablet therapieren ein
teleportieren das schwein wobei sich wo
die kripo ach so ich kann auch ein
creeper töten nur ganz kurz dafür
brauche ich jetzt mal ganz kurzen sport
sowieso da
jetzt habe ich nämlich gunpowder zum
beispiel oder contra die diesen ort
wieder skelette die lettin
wahrscheinlich gerade nicht habe ich
herkomm jetzt hier weil ich so sozial
wie mache ich mir kurz dem torch an
sorgen hier so sei die höhle auf das
monster
natürlich fällt jetzt auch ein knochen
gekriegt doch nicht so gut ich kann auch
hier mit einfach drauf gehen und
vertrieb oder halt einfach mit dem
knochen dann wäre das jetzt ein statiker
oder im knochen wir das jetzt ein
skelett da gibt es halt so eine
bestimmte tabelle die findet ihr in der
beschreibung beim motti downloadlink
komm komm bald los lachte bisher gar
nicht gesehen könnte auch den
körperformen kommt nehmen wir dann habe
ich diesen kleinen creeper das aus
natürlich weil man eine kurve läuft
bewegte sich immer ganz kurz sodann
läuft immer so ein bisschen
es geht allerdings auch zu es geht auch
einfacher und zwar kann auch einfach mit
einem stick rechtsklick auf ihn drauf
machen wie eine menge
auswahlmöglichkeiten ihn zum beispiel
mal conny übrigens wenn ihr mich schon
kontinent ich mag den namen ja nicht so
dann schreibt ihn wenigstens richtig cnn
und gott verdammt nicht cmk oops i lon
coni das was anderes ja es geht es klar
wenn ihr wie später gleich null das nach
tampa habe ich nicht eingegeben
also hier kann man es in ein leben da
muss man dann zog mit skin machen und
dann sucht man sich denken skin unklar
und es ist halt wenn der typ was
anziehen soll
so werde zum beispiel hier so manch
einer time you machen und dann kann man
als kind ausgeben und blei und wenn ich
dann zum beispiel nikon crafter ein gebe
dann hat er meinen kindern und sowas
anders halt ich kann jetzt auch hd
eingeben
es hatte gomez ging ja das sind halt ein
paar kleine features so ich nenne den
falcon crafter natürlich ganze system
auf submit skin gehen natürlich wissen
hier haben wir dann ganz oft
möglichkeiten zum beispiel spyder zombie
was auch sehr witzig ist es gibt rpgs
beider die sieht so krass täglich aus
wenn ihr die auf dem kopf habe ich habe
wieso geekelt alter das sieht so
verdammt noch mal wirklich aus ist
richtig abartig die umschlingt mehr oder
weniger euren kopf wenn nicht dann
bewegt diese lang der dackel also diese
spinne gibt es nicht so im spiel aber
ich will auch gar nicht dass die gibt
also dieses ist einfach so
wenn jetzt einmal kurz bezieht man die
gar nicht einmal kurz in die kamera
gucken spinne
das ist echt so abartig das ist richtig
war
ich finde das einfach nur eklig ich
hasse diese spinne war wenn ich das höre
ich hasse ich bin bis auf die plötzlich
hast du alles alle spinnen die die
bewegen egal wie klein wie groß ich
hasse spinn ich bin ihr unendlich busse
ich hasse sprint ist der größte alptraum
auf erden stirb so geschah etwas anderes
es gibt auch noch ein rpg bullen der
macht komische geräusche hört mal
naja eigentlich noch was anderes aber
naja und dann aber noch ein boah also
ich glaube das wildschwein oder
warzenschwein oder irgendwie so was sie
dort wird sie aus nun so viel mehr
sachen haben wir gar nicht so relativ
neu sind es gibt jetzt aber so komische
sachen wie weather skeleton oder was ist
auch gibt die fledermaus sehr schädlich
und das geilste was ich eigentlich
findet gast also das ist echt wird sich
die können übrigens auch so blöcke
einfach so hoch fliegen laufen
seht ihr jetzt wenn conny mich verfolgt
das realisiert der nach der zeit dass
ich dann einfach mal weg gelaufen bin so
da ist die können einfach so hoch kommen
also das war es auch eigentlich schon
ihr habt eure kleinen haustiere können
mit denen zurzeit noch nicht viel machen
was ich mir wünschen würde ist dass die
euch wirklich immer so verfolgen so
teleportieren gibt es ja schon
und dass sie auch items einsammeln wie
so ein rucksack und zwar wenn man zum
beispiel das weil sie nicht das monster
in höhlen auftreten wie zum beispiel
kripo oder mops oder so dass die zum
beispiel ob gegenstände einsammeln und
das schweine zb essen einsammeln oder
irgendwie sowas halt
also ich weiß nicht ob ich da ganz
versteht aber halt irgendwie sowas ist
mir auf jeden fall hammergeil und fragen
sich bestimmt einige ja wie kommt man
denn an den muss man denen sich
irgendwie kräften wenn ihr eine welt
erstellt egal ob so weibel oder creative
oder hardcore die kleine person tritt
direkt in diesem format neben euch auf
so kann man kurze kindern machen wir
ganz kurz noch mal ein foto für die
zuschauer so kommt für bitte
tschuldigung conny
dann die personen da direkt generiert
und ihr könnt geht ist das meine glaube
ich dann könnt ihr halt mit den ganzen
items die ihr dann habt halt da einfach
draufklicken auf die person also aus
diesen kleinen teilen die buddy also
dann habt ihr dann entweder rock pop
oder keine ahnung wie so was halt könnt
ihr dann einfach draufklicken dann
verwandelt er sich ein paar leute und ja
also die komplette tabelle findet ihr im
fernsehen nein natürlich nicht im
fernsehen sondern in der beschreibung
ist ein link zum download der
modifikation und der kig jetzt die ganze
zeit irgendwie anders ist ein bisschen
als guckte mich schon wieder an grad wo
ich drauf drücken möchte
conny conny kuck in die kamera rodney
buford sonst gibt's dann am kanal dessen
sie bitte sofort die kamera und ihn
sofort
sofort in die kamera gucken konnte die
kamera den termin natürlich nicht
umsonst conny conny kuck die kamera
dreht einfach ich ramprechts conny kuck
in die kamera kann die möchte ich in die
kamera gucken
connys kamera schaut conny wenn du das
nicht willst du willst du ihnen etwa zum
schwein machen hat na gut mein gott
haben wir kleinen schweine und baby
schwein und mein gott na gute freunde
das war erstmal mit dieser vorstellung
bitten und beim nächsten mal wird euch
gefallen da will ich mich mein freund
nächsten monaten wird umfangreicher
besser und geiler finde ich hatte etwas
nicht sagt nicht womit zu tun hat und
dann sehen wir uns dann bei der mode
vorstellung wieder und jetzt kommt
wieder mehr allgemeinere sachen wofür
man kann also bekannt ist musik
vorstellen vorstellung et cetera weil
jetzt habe ich auch wieder mehr zeit